hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start warning
spoilers ahead today i'm going to
explain a 2013 australian
post-apocalyptic science fiction and
thriller movie called these final hours
the movie begins with asteroids that
have just landed in the north atlantic
and kick off a firestorm of destruction
that has already taken out huge chunks
of the civilized world leaving
approximately 12 hours before the next
firestorm reaches western australia the
scene moves to perth where james and his
girlfriend zoe are enjoying their final
hours in the beach house but the moment
of happiness doesn't last long as zoe
reveals that she is pregnant which makes
james upset and angry he berates zoe for
sharing that good news because there is
no way they could spend time together
with their upcoming child feeling
frustrated and wishing to forget
everything in his final hours james
leaves his girlfriend alone to go to the
party even after zoe begs him to stay
on his way the man on the radio states
the eastern coastline of america has
been affected and all western europe has
been destroyed by the firestorm he also
states that the firestorm is currently
coming towards the nation which makes
things worse
driving through a montage of chaos where
people start getting crazy and killing
each other james suddenly is confronted
by a madman equipped with a blade
after several moments of conversation
the madman randomly gets out of the car
and stabs innocent people
james then uses the opportunity to
escape and run away he manages to dodge
the man by hiding at the bottom of a car
unfortunately while running away from
him james gets his arm hurt by a nail
he postpones his plan to head off to the
party after seeing a little girl who has
been abducted by a couple of depraved
weirdos he plans to steal the car but
when he hears the girl keep screaming he
decides to break into the house and
attempts to help the girl despite his
insistence that he no longer cares about
anything
equipped himself with a hammer he
manages to kill both of them and rescue
the girl who later introduces herself as
rose she explains that she was separated
from her father and malaga a suburb of
perth while on their way to her aunt's
house and urges james to take her there
he then decides to bring the girl to
malaga but it seems like her dad has
gone away leaving his car there
rose grabs a picture of her dad from the
car and shows it to james
while asked about her mom she says that
her mom has died on the other side
someone on the radio claims that they
still have 10 hours left
continuing his journey to the party
james stops at his sister's house hoping
to drop rose there they arrive at
james's sister's house but no one is
answering the door
he decides to break into the house
through the back door only to find out
that his sister and her husband have
committed suicide in the shower and
discover three crosses marking that
appears to be his sister's kid's graves
realizing that he is unable to reunite
rose with her father james decides to
steal his sister's car which almost runs
out of gas and take her along to the
party in hopes of finding someone there
who can take her to her family
on their way rose offers james a piece
of cloth to stop his arm from bleeding
suddenly they spot a police car stopping
by and decide to approach the man
james asks the man whether he can leave
rose with them because he is a policeman
the man refuses and tells james that he
has given up on life begging and
ordering james to kill him with his
family instead
james refuses and leaves with rose the
policeman finally decides to do it
himself both of them finally arrive at
the party which turns out to be freddie
james's friend wild party the party is
overflowing with people even russian
roulette is played there people getting
killed is a normal thing there they
don't even feel scared or sad after one
of the guys shoots himself in the
roulette game instead they are
celebrating james eventually meets the
party owner whose sister is james's
other girlfriend
seeing the party has gone wild rose is
noticeably uncomfortable and urges james
to leave
he finally meets vicki and goes to a
room with her telling rose to play alone
in the pool vicky forces james to have
fun with her but james seems to be not
in the mood because he just saw his
sister die
she even offers him to consume some
drugs but james refuses
after that she shows a banker that was
built underneath freddie's garage which
she claims can protect them from the
apocalypse james says that everyone
including him vicky and freddie will die
because the bunker will not work as it
is not deep enough and does not have
sufficient food stocks
that statement disappoints vicki and
turns her into a mad woman claiming that
she doesn't want to die and forces james
to kiss her suddenly freddie comes into
the bunker just only to heathen up the
situation there he insists that the
bunker will save them from the firestorm
while james keeps telling him to stop
talking nonsense
at the pool rose is approached by a mad
woman who wants her to replace her
vanish daughter
rose is also forced to consume an
ecstasy pill
at first she refuses to do so but when
the mad woman claims that she can take
her to her aunt's house rose finally
takes the pill which makes her
hallucinate and dizzy
james gets back to the party where he
finds roses vomiting at the corner of
the hall with the madwoman leaning over
her she is in a very bad condition after
taking that pill
when james tries to leave the party with
rose the mad woman starts screaming
saying that james is trying to kidnap
her kid
suddenly freddy appears and aims his gun
at james telling him to put rose down
but then vicky calmly takes the gun from
freddie and shoots the mad woman to
death telling james to go away
rose's condition is getting worse and
james decides to bring her to his
estranged mother's house
after a long walk james manages to steal
a cab and drives it away
james treats rose like she is his
daughter as he lays her down on a bed
and rests there as she recovers we can
see that the relationship between james
and his mom is not that great later she
asks james whether he has been hearing
about his sister's condition but james
lies not telling his mother that she is
dead his mother reveals that she visited
james sister a while ago but no one
answered the door not even the girls
claiming that james sister was very
selfish for not allowing her to see her
own grandkids and blaming james sister's
husband for that
when asked how she is going to spend her
last hours james's mom states that she
is just going to finish her jigsaw
puzzles
james decides to continue his plan to
take rose to her family his mom gives
james some petrol she kept in the garage
before leaving james says his final
words and goodbye to his mom holding her
hand for the last time
on the journey the same man from the
radio states that southeast asia is
completely gone indicating that it will
only take several hours for the
firestorm before it reaches australia
long story short both of them finally
arrive at rose's aunt's house
upon arrival rose is very excited
because finally she is able to meet his
father
but nobody seems to be home as they have
explored the whole house and cannot find
anyone while walking towards the garden
james manages to find rose's whole
family including her father but only
their dead body although hysterical at
the news of her father's death rose
insists on seeing him james calms her
down and eventually allows her to see
her father's dead body
james covers rose's father with a cloth
brings him to rose and lays him by the
pond when james asks her to go with him
rose insists that she wants to be on her
father's side until the end saying that
her dad wants them to be together when
it happens
james then confides in rose about his
relationship with zoe and her pregnancy
which leads him to realize his love for
her rose convinces him to make amends
with her while there is still enough
time he accepts her advice and the two
share an emotional farewell before they
split ways
james then drives away leaving rose
alone in her aunt's house
unfortunately the cab overheats and
explodes on the highway as the firestorm
approaches forcing james to run the rest
of the way
eventually he arrives at the beach house
on time but can't find zoey in there
while the storm is getting closer he
runs out and manages to find zoey on the
beach watching the approaching firestorm
at first she is very mad at james and
not allowing him to get closer
however james apologizes for what he had
done and the two quickly reconcile and
confess their love for the last time the
pair then embrace and turn towards the
ocean as they are killed by the
firestorm
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching